vous et le président Trump avez-ils une
bonne relation, vous me dites qu'à
un moment donné, vous avez réalisé que c'était un
gars avec qui je pouvais travailler, j'étais un tout
début, je veux dire que j'ai observé sa campagne
et j'ai observé ses premiers pas comme des prismes d'
abord  tout ce que je veux dire les états-unis  les gens ont
décidé d'élire le président Trump et
il est très déterminé il je veux dire il sait
ce qu'il veut parfois nous sommes d'accord
parfois nous ne sommes pas d'accord mais dès le
début j'ai décidé que nous nous n'avons pas
nous pouvons travailler ensemble et nous avons
des échanges très directs des échanges directs
et  une relation
très chaleureuse depuis la toute première réunion
en juin 2017, je pense que j'ai compris que c'était
quelque chose que je suis juste faisable que certains
c'est la meilleure option possible que vous soyez venu
ici aux États-Unis pour poursuivre
l'accord avec l'Iran à quel point  vous
obtenez tout d'abord je suis le but de ma
visite n'était pas seulement qu'il s'agit d'une première
visite d'État de l'administration des peines de prison
donc votre objectif est pour une
telle visite d'État est avant tout de
renforcer l'amitié
renforce la relation bilatérale et établit
des relations personnelles  dans cette base avec les
dirigeants ont des échanges directs avec le
peuple c'est un régime que j'ai pris était des
entretiens de serveur avec adresse au congrès
et fractionnement econo  mic
partenariats culturels scientifiques et je pense qu'avec
la variable de retour en plus de cela,
nous sommes évidemment dans une situation où
nos deux pays peuvent vous dire que c'est un
rôle sur l'Iran et la Syrie et différents
problèmes et commerce ainsi que pour former l'Iran
mon point de vue  était d'éviter juste les
États-Unis.  passer et se débarrasser d'eux
c'est un jcpoa La France fait évidemment du JCP
parce qu'on l'a signé exactement comme
les US mais on a réussi à construire un nouveau
scénario avec un nouveau deal global
avec le contenu du contenu du
jcpoa
la solution 2025 passée pour
armes nucléaires, l'endiguement du régime iranien
dans la région et une
discussion très approfondie sur les
missiles balistiques et en prison.
La Syrie dans
ce surcadre et justement pour convaincre les
peines de prison que nous avons nos soldats
sur le terrain et ça va dès que
le travail d'Isis sera terminé nous
partirons mais notre responsabilité est au-delà de
la guerre contre Isis et je pense que maintenant nous
nous sommes mis d'accord  sur ce qui est très
important pour moi pensez-vous que le
président Trump est incompris en
Europe je ne sais pas je pense que la prison
Tramp ISM définitivement le leader élu
aux US  a la difference parfois
avec des approches differentes il a
un style tres personnel et est tres controverse
meme aux u.s.  donc je pense qu'en Europe
beaucoup de gens qui le respectent bien,
certaines personnes ne comprennent pas
automatiquement ses décisions mais je pense
que ce n'est pas une question pour moi, la question centrale
est de savoir comment jouer avec parce que c'est
définitivement une relation transatlantique
est absolument critique dans le
contexte actuel, nous devons donc construire ensemble,
nous devons travailler et je pense que ce que
je voulais transmettre comme message lors de
la visite d'État, c'était le fait que nos
deux pays partageaient cette histoire très forte
de la révolution américaine à la
Des révolutions françaises à la première guerre mondiale la seconde
guerre mondiale et nous devons être je veux dire le
pétrole et dans la ligne de ceci est cette
histoire commune et c'est très important
pour moi et je pense que lorsque vous enchâssez les
gens dans cette histoire commune lorsque
vous essayez les gens  dans ce couplet du
destin ça réduit beaucoup tous les
écarts tu peux avoir cette notion
de moi aussi
tu en penses quoi parce que toi
tu as des divergences d'opinion en
France - Kather  ine - pas d'autres je veux dire je
veux dire je suis un fervent croyant je veux dire et
je dois dire que je ne m'attendais pas au
mouvement car quand j'ai lancé mon
mouvement nous avons organisé
une marche pour aller vers les gens et
comprendre ce qu'ils voulaient  étaient ce
qu'ils ressentaient et ainsi de suite l'un des principaux
sujets dont les gens ne discutent jamais une très
très grande discussion dans le domaine politique était
précisément le harcèlement des femmes et la violence
contre les femmes c'est pourquoi je l'ai mis dans mon
programme pendant la campagne et c'était l'
une de mes clés  objectifs et j'ai décidé
d'en faire une grande cause pour le
forum pour mon mandat l'égalité femmes-hommes et la
lutte contre la violence des femmes donc je suis depuis
convaincue qu'il faut
préserver l'égalité femmes-hommes et et nous
devons lutter personnellement contre tout cela
genre de harcèlement comme pour le mouvement du mètre
on voit effectivement des
expressions différentes mais je pense que ce qu'il faut
garder a un message clé c'est pas de tolérance
pour les gens qui se comportent comme ça
n'accepte jamais le harcèlement sexuel n'accepte jamais
ce respect  de l'égalité des sexes parce que
cela fait partie de notre ADN cela fait partie de notre
société, donc je crois fermement en ce
grand changement avez-vous l'impression
que c'est un peu différent
information sur la sensibilité culturelle non je
pense dans notre culture  maintenant dans nos
pays vous aviez des
expressions différentes et ainsi de suite et c'est normal
mais pour moi je veux m'en tenir à ce
message noriko essentiel et obtenir des
résultats parce que je pense que ce que nous devons
faire est maintenant sur la base de ce
mouvement très spécifique  est de changer notre
société dans une telle société informelle pour que
quelqu'un dulcis l'égalité des sexes et
se débarrasse du harcèlement sexuel et de la
violence merci